every day we bring you examples of the
grim reality of this latest covid surge
that includes conversations with
patients and loved ones doctors and
nurses
and today we speak with emergency
workers who see patients before they get
to the hospital
almost all of the covet patients who
need their help have not received a
vaccine our lead national correspondent
david begno rode along with a crew in
louisiana to find out what they're up
against
how long have you been waiting
i have been waiting for three days three
days yeah you've been here for three
days
huh
yes three days oh my god wow what's your
name ma'am julia we were right there
when 48 year old julia clay was loaded
into the back of an acadian ambulance
and transported to our lady of lourdes
regional medical center in lafayette
louisiana
59 percent of the beds here are filled
with covet patients and 93 percent of
them are unvaccinated
and now clay is one of them
[Music]
you wish you would have taken the
vaccine yeah
acadian ambulance which is based in
louisiana is the largest privately owned
ambulance company in the country
we spent three days with them
dr chuck burnell is their chief medical
officer of your call volume how much is
dominated by covid patients around 30 to
40 percent of our call volume involves
covet patients 211 i'm in route 27 year
old trent tarbutton
is a field supervisor for acadia i think
we have three of them right now we're
currently waiting he took us to
lafayette general where ambulances were
backed up because there were no er beds
available recently medics have had to
wait here with patients anywhere from 30
minutes to three hours we kind of just
have to tell the hospital like look find
something that we don't care where you
put this patient you have to put them
somewhere because we need to run
emergencies tar button's supervisor is
keisha trojan we're all drowning we're
all drowning and sucking air through a
straw but people will say it's not as
bad as you're saying it is um i would
tell them they might want to come work
in ems
come come come in the er
com because
the nurses feel it we feel it
this coveted surge has also forced
acadian to transfer some patients out of
state
louisiana has a call center in baton
rouge that is focused on finding
available beds and advanced care for
patients around the state
all right so y'all can't accept we were
there when trauma care coordinators
david mccarroll and allison lafitte
tried finding a bed for an elderly man
in central louisiana who had gone into
cardiac arrest hey it's allison at learn
again there were 15 hospitals within 100
miles but they told us they could not
find a single available bed they have no
beds no staff to take care of it
that's where we're at today
and that's where we've been
okay so y'all not gonna do y'all not
gonna transfer
after two hours looking lafitte says the
doctor told them the patient's condition
had worsened and he could no longer be
transferred he
has since gone back into cardiac arrest
a couple of times
it's been a roller coaster ride for the
family again dr chuck burnell a lot of
patients that we deem
would not probably benefit from the
hospital are already being treated in
place at home and being left at home
they have not refused to transport
anyone
yet we're days away from that happening
right now less than a week it's the
unthinkable but he's got to juggle other
priorities too like speaking almost
daily with medics who are not vaccinated
two of those unvaccinated employees you
met at the start of our story
they are the two medics who transported
julia clay the covet positive patient to
the hospital transporting it you're up
close with it
does that not change your opinion
no
i'm very like me and my family are very
religious we pray a lot
we've always been the type of people
that we trust god are you vaccinated no
[Music]
no should i be yes
yes i should be vaccinated that is very
careless of me
you know because i do come in contact
with other people will i be vaccinated
so yes you have more exposure
than most anybody else yes and you still
haven't gotten it i have it oh
do i push it yes i do i push it yes get
you back you mean pushing in terms of oh
telling other people what i do but you
haven't done a hypocrite if they were
offering it right now would you take it
yes
and that's why it's confusing guys to
people when they see medical workers
that say i'm not going to get it either
well we have an update on that what is
it chianti williams the woman we saw at
the very end there she has subsequently
been vaccinated you see her there so
that that's good news all around but i i
my my jaw just drops boggles your mind
at the back of the ambulance say i won't
do it but did you also hear keante
williams say yes i'm a hypocrite i'm a
hypocrite yeah i'm telling people to get
it
i i always say she said like she went to
the doctor
she wanted to get it she sounds like she
was very busy her colleague however
though had different ideas about it well
what's new tony i don't even know how
you could be too busy during this time
this delta variant is no joke well i
don't know
anything else how many stories like this
do you have to see but the scary part
isn't just that you will get sick yes
but now they're not even able to find
beds for people in hospitals in some
areas because they're so full and if 30
to 40 of the calls for the ambulance are
now covert related what about all the
other calls that are happening anyway
yeah i worry about that right